un visuel spectacle de danse poésie et
expériences scientifiques
quatre axes du programme culturel de la
commanderie de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
mise en avant lors de la soirée
d'inauguration ce lieu incarne à la fois
une dimension historique importante
c'est un lieu emblématique pour
l'agglomération et en même temps il se
veut accompagner l'émission culturelle
pour la saison qui s'annonce c'est un
espèce de lieux privilégiés à part dans
la ville sur le territoire on laisse
quasiment le décor extérieur à
l'extérieur et on est dans un autre lieu
curieux d'art et ça c'est magique et
c'est rare une soirée d'inauguration
point de départ d'une saison qui
s'annonce riche
les moments forts les premiers qui me
vient à l'idée ce sera les journées de
la science important très importante
parce que là la mission science et est
importante notamment pour pour les
enfants et puis l'autre événement un
autre événement de grande convivialité
qui sera le noël des cas les voilà au
mois de décembre
en attendant c'est un moment chaleureux
et festif qui a été proposé aux saint
quentinois 450 personnes ont répondu
présent à l'appel malgré les
restrictions sanitaires en vigueur
là encore à saint quentin en yvelines la
culture entre en résistance face au co
vide
les espaces se sont remplis les publics
vont et viennent donc on est très
heureux il y à tous les âges sont
représentés
donc c'était vraiment notre ambition de
pouvoir réunir les familles et puis
toutes les générations
prochain rendez vous les journées
européennes du patrimoine les 19 et 27
ans